so the last of the katata movements
katatahachi nojigashi
um if you can
think of a figure eight on its side
this is the pattern you strike their
temple
on both sides
a lot of people like this one because it
gives them a buzz you know
but most people are doing it with the
wrists so
that's not correct
align it with your back foot
you might have to look down and go
against my
thoughts here align with your back foot
it comes forward the body
forward and then the hips forward
and then the hips it strikes
their temple keep this low
not high if you have it high
the joe starts to get heavy if you have
right
when i was younger i used to practice
holding it here
for as long as i could and i found that
if i think
here at the wrist it it gets heavy
if i think of extending out the end of
the joe
i could hold it there longer so it might
be worth
trying this as an exercise
so you strike exactly you're trying to
get this even pattern
even pattern and then at the end of it
you
like with hasso you settle the body
into a stance and you settle the body
so
try not to let what i call the joe sag
not too close not too far
comfortable unbendable arm
unbendable arm position it's not too
far not too close
elbow too high joe is heavy
joe drops down comes over the top
shoulders out drop it
feel a bit cramped okay
look for your weaknesses don't criticize
yourself too much
try to tick one off at a time try and
take one
error off at a time and just but being
but notice be aware of your own faults
video yourself when you can and check it
out afterwards
don't worry about self-criticism uh
it's better than someone else shouting
at you
the footwork
stepping forward as you're striking
their temple
slide back
step forward
slide back settle
the movement and the sliding will depend
on how you're feeling
and how you're doing it sometimes the
feet come together
sometimes the feet come together
okay so what i
found yeah for many years is
i get tense i'm sort of trying to enjoy
and yet i'll find it into it
oh i need to relax i'm getting too tired
so loosen yourself loosen yourself
all the things i tell you the things i
experience
and of course if i was told it earlier i
might be wiser but most of the teachers
just tell you how to do the techniques
they don't tell you the pitfalls that
you have as a human being
ah
because you once used tense that time
that's what you ask yourself
okay so sometimes slowly with the neck
sometimes the shoulders
we get up tight because we're trying too
hard sometimes we're enjoying it too
much we don't realize the tension in our
body
so that's the end of the three kata
movements the next set will be the
hasso movements
i hope i've covered all the things that
i can consider
with those three if i think of any more
any time i will
i'll add them but please take your time
don't worry about
just watching the films and going out
there thinking
that you're going to get it all in one
go because you're not
it's a very long road but it should be
an enjoyable one
thanks for your time